Tick Tock is at a Crossroads concerns
about its Chinese ownership have been
building since 2020. tick tock's been in
this limo for two years and who knows
how many more months or years it could
stay in this limbo and a panel of U.S
officials is torn on how to address them
if they can't come to an agreement
there's another possible solution
forcing Tick Tock to become a U.S
company
here's what it would take to make that
happen and why that move poses some big
challenges
first A Brief Review of how tick tock's
data is managed which is the main focus
for U.S officials tick tock's a huge
company but it's owned by a Chinese
parent company called bite dance they
run several apps but tick tock's
probably their best known one in the
world by dance itself is headquartered
in Beijing and is owned by investors
from around the globe a Chinese
state-controlled entity owns one percent
of a beijing-based subsidiary of bite
dance those connections are what some
are worried about and for a couple of
reasons the first concern is that the
Chinese government could order Tick-Tock
to hand over data about individual
American users so what what kind of
videos they watch and maybe even their
IP addresses which could identify their
location the second big thing is the
video recommendation algorithm and the
idea is that the Chinese government
could order Tick-Tock to control what
videos Americans could watch Tick Tock
says it has already started to address
some of those concerns the company
recently said that all us use traffic is
now being routed through Cloud servers
operated by the us-based company Oracle
and Tick Tock says that only members of
its U.S data security team have access
to that data but backups are still being
saved to other non-oracle servers in the
US and Singapore the company says but
it's phasing those out as for tick
tock's recommendation algorithm that was
created by its Chinese parent company
bite dance Tick Tock says changes to the
algorithm are monitored by Oracle before
they are implemented in the US app so at
any time there's a change to the
algorithm that influences what kind of
videos Americans see they say that
Oracle will have full access to see you
know what the algorithm does
spokesperson for the Chinese foreign
Ministry said in a press conference in
November in regards to tick tock that
spreading disinformation and then using
it to hobble Chinese companies has
become a go-to tool for the US
government but some U.S lawmakers still
want Tick Tock to have more separation
from China
one option is to divestiture order or a
for sale which could cut ties to Chinese
ownership the Chinese government would
theoretically have less power over Tick
Tock to to force Tick Tock to do
something like spy or controlled videos
Americans watch a divestiture order is
what happened to the dating app grinder
in 2019 after U.S officials determined
that the app's personal data could
potentially be exploited for blackmail
since the majority stakeholder was a
Chinese company here's how the process
has worked in past cases
first an executive body branch called
the committee on foreign investment in
the United States or cepheus opens a
case with the involved companies this is
the panel that's been talking to tick
tock it's made up of Representatives of
nine U.S departments and agencies led by
the treasury and reviews foreign
transactions to see if they might be a
national security risk after cypheus
reviews accompany our merger it can make
recommendations to mitigate those risks
which can include asking foreign
investors or owners to sell their stake
in the company in extreme cases it can
also escalate the case to the president
who can order a forced sale
that owner then has to find a suitable
buyer usually one within the us then the
buyer and seller might have to go back
to civius in order to get the sale
approved Grindr took just over a year
after the order was made to find a buyer
and get approval the president never
issued an order but Tick Tock is a much
bigger name and forcing a sale could be
more complicated there's been nothing of
the scale this popularity usually you
know cypheus deals with a lot smaller
cases here so this is uh this is like
the case of the century for cypheus
lawyers in Washington D.C a treasury
official said that siphius does not
publicly comment on transactions that it
may or may not be reviewing officials
are worried about a number of challenges
facing a forced sale one is that the
Trump Administration already tried it
they have till September 15th to make a
deal after that we close it up in this
country in 2020 that Administration
issued an order that would have
effectively banned Tick Tock unless it
sold itself to a U.S buyer but Tick Tock
pushed back and took the order to a
federal appeals court arguing that the
deal denied the company due process it
was still tied up in legal issues by the
time Joe Biden got into office and the
order was shelved as his administration
conducted its own Security review
but his administration could face
similar pushback from Tick Tock if it
tries to force a sale and doing so could
risk diluting cypheus's Authority there
are powers based on having these vague
broad powers and if they go to court
even if they win in court a court might
put parameters on that power might
Define that power because the more vague
your power is the more powerful it is
even without legal hurdles a sale would
also need cooperation from the Chinese
government which has the power to
restrict the exports of Technology such
as tick tock's video recommendation
algorithm
China does not allow the algorithm to be
sold then can Tick Tock continue
operating in the U.S we don't know we're
in totally uncharted waters right now
while civius decides what to do some
lawmakers have taken concerns into their
own hands Tick Tock has been banned on
government devices in a majority of
states and in December the federal
government implemented a similar ban the
only sensible next step is for this
Congress to act to make that ban across
the board for all federal devices at
least one bill has been introduced to
ban take talk entirely in the United
States that has legal problems too that
that could potentially face a First
Amendment problem can you can you
actually stop can you actually ban Tick
Tock from operating in the U.S
especially when it has more than 100
million American users well Tick Tock
has made concessions including how its
data is managed to get to an agreement
with cypheus talks are ongoing without a
clear deadline
foreign
[Music]